DAVID CHANDLER: Good morning.
What a crowd.
We speculated when Google I/O
sold out in 59 minutes.
By the way, congratulations to
all of you who set places in
your calendars that you were
going to get an I/O ticket
this year no matter what.
It's a great testimony to the
excitement about Google
Technologies and APIs that
you're all here.
And we're very glad for that.
But when we sold out so
quickly there was some
speculation, is this because
people just want the free
phones or devices?
And the fact that we have over
200 people here in this room,
standing room only, to hear talk
about GWT says to me, no,
you came for the code.
So thank you very much.
My name is David Chandler.
I work with the Google Web
Tool Kit team in Atlanta.
And we're going to talk this
morning about some third-party
tools that you can use for
productive GWT development.
And with that, we'll go
ahead and get started.
So first, we're going
to talk about
third-party tools in general.
And then we're going to speak
about Objectify-Appengine,
which is useful on
the server side.
Then I'm going to cover the new
RequestFactory features in
GWT 2.1 and then Philippe
Beaudoin will talk about the
gwt-platform framework
for MVP development.
So we want to mention
some third-party
tools that are useful.
Google can write a line
of code, but we don't
write all the code.
We rely on third-party
open source projects
to do an awful lot.
And of course, we contribute
to get those
things started as well.
But one tool that you can use
for GWT and App Engine
development is Maven.
And I just want to highlight
because there were some issues
using Maven with Google Plugin
for Eclipse in the past. We've
made a big effort to make those
work better together.
And you can now import an
existing Maven project in
Eclipse and your Google Plugin
in for Eclipse stuff will be
all configured.
With your App Engine STKs will
come from the Maven POM as
well as your GWT STKs.
And it works much better than
it has in the past.
So this is a great--
[APPLAUSE].
Thank you.
So let me ask, how many
people use Maven?
OK.
Lots.
How many people love Maven?
OK.
How many people hate Maven?
Some of the same hands.
All right.
We understand.
But it's a useful tool.
So we want to try and support
it as best we can.
And two third-party projects
that are very important to
that are the Maven GAE Plugin
and the GWT Maven Plugin.
And we're really glad that they
took this on because they
did those plugins before we
supported it and Google Plugin
for Eclipse.
And we rely on the community
for this so
that's great stuff.
Now on the App Engine datastore
side there have
been, besides the JDO and JPA
interface that Google
produces, there is Twig, Sim3,
Symbol DS, Objectify.
There's lots of different
frameworks that have been
developed to help people
with persistence.
And then on the front
end side, lots of
model-view-presenter
frameworks.
Mvp4g, gwt-presenter and
dispatch, and gwt-platform are
frameworks you've probably
all heard of.
So these are just some tools
if you're getting started
researching these topics.
Good places to go and look.
So what we're going to do this
morning is kind of work from
back to front.
We're going to start on the
server side and talk about the
App Engine datastore in
Objectify, a framework that
can help you there.
Then move up to RequestFactory
which is GWT's new RPC layer.
And then at the top we'll have
gwt-platform and how you can
use it to build
model-view-presenter UIs.
So with that, I'm very pleased
this morning to have with us
the creator of Appengine
Objectify Jeff Schnitzer.
Jeff, please come on up.
JEFF SCHNITZER: Hello.
It worked.
Oh where's the clicker?
All right.
I'm going to give you a very,
very brief introduction to
what I'm calling the simplest,
convenient interface to the
App Engine datastore.
But first, I have a little
confession to make, and that's
that I hate writing tools.
I'm an entrepreneur, and every
day that I spend writing tools
is a day that I'm not adding a
feature to an application that
might someday make me
rich and successful.
But I use a lot of tools, and
it's very important to me to
use good tools.
If you ever walk into the back
of the workspace of an
automotive or motorcycle
mechanic, you'll find well,
first, a number of posters
of half-naked women.
But second, you'll find a big
box of Snap-On Tools.
Snap-On Tools are
very expensive.
A wrench that will cost maybe
$10 at Sears will set you back
about $50 from Snap-On.
There's nothing wrong with
the Craftsman tool.
I've got a garage full of them,
and let me tell you they
turn bolts just fine.
But if you hold the Snap-On tool
in your hand, the polish
is a little bit better.
The weighting is a little
bit better.
It's just slightly nicer
ergonomically.
And if you spend every day of
your life working with tools,
when you have slightly nicer
tools, it actually improves
your quality of life.
So when I started working on App
Engine a year and a half
ago, I started out with
JDA and JPO--
excuse me.
JPO and JDA.
Well, my quality of
life was not good.
This kind of surprised me,
because I'm actually a really
big fan of JPA.
I've been doing Java EE
development professionally for
about a decade.
I've been using Hibernate
version 1.0 and I've got Gavin
King on speed dial.
But still, it was a struggle.
And I tried to figure out why.
I realized that there's two
basic problems. One, there's a
lot of stuff in JDO and JPA that
just don't really apply
to App Engine.
And second of all, there's a
lot of stuff in App Engine
that just was never accounted
for when they
designed JPA and JDO.
You can't develop an application
on App Engine
without understanding at some
level how keys work, how
entity groups work, and the
particular quirks of indexes
on App Engine.
And because of this there's four
learning curves that I
had to climb.
First, how do you represent your
Java data structures with
JPA or JDO?
How do you manage the giant
DataNucleus software package
which implements that?
There's actually the DataNucleus
plugin that Google
writes that maps from the
whatever they put out on the
back end to the low
level data store.
And then there's how should my
data actually be represented
natively in the datastore
itself?
To make this especially fun, the
documentation for all of
these learning curves
is spread out
all over the internet.
And so I was running to and
fro different websites.
When I took a step back and
said, OK this is crazy.
I realized the only one of these
learning curves that
really matters is, how should my
data look in the datastore?
Because this is what
controls what is my
application going to cost?
How long is it going to take
my queries to return?
Will I be able to get
the answers to my
queries that I want?
So of course, I went straight to
the low-level API, which at
the time was documented
only in Java Docs.
And I realized something.
I realized that the App Engine
datastore is actually really
simple and really elegant.
There's really only
four operations.
You can get data out
of the datastore.
You can put data in
the datastore.
You can delete it.
And then you can query for it.
And the low-level API is not
really all that bad.
You've got these simple entity
data structures.
It's basically a HashMap.
You can key it by string.
You can put some data in, you
can take some data out.
But it's a little bit too simple
for all the reasons
that we invented compilers
and type checkers.
It's really not very pleasant
working with HashMaps.
And the datastore itself
has a few funny quirks.
If you put numbers into an
entity, it'll always
come back as a long.
If you put a set of data into
the entity, it'll come back as
a list.
So what I really wanted
was just objects.
We're used to working with
objects, nice tight
structures.
So I decided that I'm going to
write a thin layer that works
just like the low-level API
does, but that lets me work
with objects.
It simply objectifies
the low-level API.
And so here is an example
of an Objectify entity.
There's only one required
annotation.
You have to define an ID.
And it uses the ID annotation.
Other than that you can use
enums You can have almost any
type involved you want.
Getting an entity out of the
datastore is very simple.
You pass in the class and
an ID, and you can
get back the entity.
There's also a batch operation
for doing this.
Putting data into
the datastore.
Create an object, put
it in the datastore.
There's a batch operation
as well.
Deleting entities.
Simple, straightforward.
There's also as you can
guess there's a
batch delete operation.
And for any of you that use
the Python version of App
Engine, the querying API should
actually seem very simple.
Should seem very familiar.
So that's the briefest
introduction to it.
A year and a half later, there's
been quite a lot of
new features added.
I'm not the only one committing
code anymore.
We've added asynchronous
operations,
true polymorphic queries.
So you can ask for all the
mammals, and get back the cats
and the dogs, but
not the lizards.
Partial indexes.
Parallel transactions.
Embedded objects and
collections.
Serialized object graphs.
And then two things that
really I use a lot.
A lot.
Automatic memcaching.
So if you just put a little
annotation, @cached, on your
entities, they'll automatically
be pulled
efficiently in and out
of the memchache.
And a set of tools which we've
sort of worked out over time
are necessary to make fairly
radical schema changes.
They allow you to make fairly
radical schema changes without
experiencing any downtime
whatsoever.
And with that, I will hand off
to the next presenter.
DAVID CHANDLER: Thanks
very much, Jeff.
So let's talk about the
middle layer now.
In 2.1, GWT put out a new RPC
layer called RequestFactory.
And I want to use this time to
introduce RequestFactory to
you, and then also show you
how it can be used with
Objectify in a GWT
application.
So there are four ways
of doing RPC in GWT.
We've had for a long time the
RequestBuilder with either the
XMLParser or the JSONParser.
So you can connect to any XML
or JSON feed via XML HTTP
request. There's GWT RPC which
allows you to send and receive
POJOs on the wire and
automatically handles the
serialization and
deserialization.
And most recently, we've
introduced RequestFactory.
And you might ask, well why
did we need another RPC
framework in GWT?
A lot of people are using
GWT RPC very happily.
And the answer is there's a few
limitations or problems,
especially when you
get the larger
applications using GWT RPC.
One of them is that GWT RPC
creates a custom serializer
and deserializer
for each class.
Sorry.
Not custom.
It automatically generates it.
But there's one per class.
So if you have a lot of classes
that you're sending
and receiving over the wire,
you're going to get a lot of
extra Java script
to do all that.
Serialize, deserialize.
And this can also lead to what
we call accidental type
explosions, where because it
supports polymorphism, if you
use an interface type like List,
and send that over the
wire, GWT RPC has to create a
serializer and deserializer
for array lists, linked
lists and all the
concrete types of lists.
So that adds to compile time as
well as to the size of your
resulting Java script.
And finally, we've been talking
in recent years about
the command pattern and
recommending the use of that
in GWT applications.
And GWT RPC doesn't support
it directly.
Now there are excellent
frameworks like gwt-dispatch
that do implement the command
pattern in GWT RPC.
But it's a little heavy
class-wise, as we'll see here.
And it's not built in.
So RequestFactory neither uses
nor replaces GWT RPC.
It is it's own thing entirely.
It's actually based on JSON
under the covers.
But we have our own protocol
that we add on top of that.
It's designed for data-oriented
services.
So it's especially
well-suited for
persistence layer type services.
It doesn't have to be, but it
has that concept in mind.
It acknowledges the
DTO problem.
So one of the things that
faces developers--
when you try to send your
objects from server to client,
there's a lot of your
server-side energies whether
they be JPA, JPO or Objectify
or something else, they're
going to have annotations in
them that have meaning for the
server-side framework.
But GWT is a Java to Java
script compiler.
So in order to do that Java
script compilation, we have to
have the Java source for
every bit of Java code.
Well, the GWT compiler doesn't
know about the Java source for
JPA, JDO and Objectify,
for example.
So you wouldn't be able to
serialize those objects
properly and send it
back and forth.
So there's several
ways around this.
One is to use GWT's supersource
capability.
And Objectify actually
supports that.
There's other frameworks like
Gilead or Hibernate that will
make GWT aware of the source
even though it's not the
actual server source.
It'll make GWT think it has the
source for an annotation,
say, so that it can be
used on the client.
And that's nice.
It's very convenient,
because then you can
send the same object.
Just have one representation
of your entity, and send it
back and forth.
But there are some difficulties
with that as well.
There have been recent changes
to the App Engine datastore
key structure which make
that more difficult.
And also you can get--
sorry, I lost my train
of thought there.
There's some kinds of
server-side activities which
you just may not ever be able
to represent in GWT.
And so at some point, you
may have to use DTOs.
So what's the problem
with DTOs?
The problem is that now you have
two representations of
your entity, which is a pain.
And also, you have to manually
copy on the server side.
When a request comes in, you
have to copy from the DTO to
the real server entity.
And then, when it goes back
out, you have to copy the
properties from the real server
entity back to the DTO.
There's a lot of boilerplate
type stuff
required to do that.
So RequestFactory acknowledges
this problem.
And it uses a DTO pattern, but
in a very light-weight way.
What we do is allow you to
find an interface on the
client side that represents
your entity.
And so you only have to worry
about the signature, if you
will, of the entity.
Just the getters and setters.
And then the RequestFactory
code takes care of
automatically instantiating that
interface and populating
all the getters and setters
for you so that you're not
having to do that tedious
type of copy code.
So that's one benefit.
Another one is that
RequestFactory is at a higher
level of abstraction.
So you can use the
command pattern.
It's built in with the
request object.
It already provides batching.
In 2.3, you can batch requests
within services.
And in 2.4, you'll actually
be able to batch
across services as well.
We enabled the RPC persistence
layers to be created with
minimal boilerplate as you'll
see here this morning.
And then RequestFactory also
tracks changes to your
entities on the client
side, and it sends
only difs to the server.
So some payload shrinkage
becomes
possible because of that.
Also now, we're happy to
announce that RequestFactory
has gone mobile.
And you can write one
RequestFactory service
implementation, post it on App
Engine or some other platform,
and consume that service from
both a GWT client as well as a
native Android client.
And to facilitate that, we've
moved RequestFactory out from
underneath the GWT package
structure into
com.google.web.binary so
it can be shared by
Android code as well.
And we think that's going to
be attractive for a lot of
people in the near term who
still need a richer user
experience than you can get
with a GWT app on mobile.
Although we're improving
that as fast as we can.
But if you have a native
app this makes it easy.
At least you only have write
your service side once.
So let's take a look at what it
takes to get started with
RequestFactory here.
First of all, in your gwt.xml,
you need an inherits to bring
in the module.
You have to map the
RequestFactory
servlet in your web.xml.
And then, what you're going to
do is create DTO interfaces
representing all your entities
and value types.
We'll talk about that
in a second.
You'll have your service stubs
just like in GWT RPC.
It's just an interface.
You have RequestFactory class
which extends the GWT
RequestFactory interface, and
that's what ties it together
and tells about all
your services.
And then finally to make it all
happen you just GWT.create
your RequestFactory class.
So let's talk about some
concepts, terminology, define
some terms here.
An entity is something that
has ID inversion.
So it's probably like
a car in a fleet
represented in a database.
And it's likely represented
by a row in a table.
A value type would be more like
a column in the table.
It's something that doesn't have
ID inversion, maybe the
color of the car.
A proxy type is a RequestFactory
term for the
interface that you create on the
client side to represent
one of these server side
entities or value types.
And the proxy types are shared
between the client and server.
And as we'll see in a moment,
they're in a shared package.
The RequestFactory code in GWT
automatically creates and
tracks instances of your
interfaces using the new
AutoBeans framework.
And this is available to
use for other purposes
if you want in GWT.
But it happens to be
the plumbing behind
RequestFactory.
A little bit about what this
means is that RequestFactory
will actually create an instance
of an interface.
OK, wait.
How can you do that?
And you could do it using an
anonymous interclass or
something, but that's not
what I'm talking about.
You'll see in a minute, you can
just call Service.create,
and give it your
interface type.
And you'll get back an instance
of that interface.
Because RequestFactory actually
creates the instance,
it can register visitors.
It supports the visitor pattern
on your instance.
And so it knows whenever
a setter has been
called on your entity.
And because it is able to know
when the setters have been
called, it can determine
when there's changes.
And this in fact is what allows
RequestFactory to keep
track of changes, and send only
changes the the client.
So by giving RequestFactory
control of creating your
instances, you're allowing it
to do smart things for you.
Then finally, a service stub is
just our service interface
analogous to our remote service
class and GWT RPC.
In RequestFactory, it's called
RequestContext--
is the class that
you'll extend.
So on the server side--
and I'm trying a little
color coding
experiment here this morning.
I apologize if you're red/green
color blind.
But we'll try to use position
to indicate it as well.
But you can remember RGB,
server, shared, client.
RGB going across.
So on the server
things are red.
This is where we're going to
have our entities and our
service implementations.
We'll also have something called
locators, which we'll
talk about a little bit later.
In the middle, we have
the shared package.
And this is all just
interfaces.
And then our actual client code
that calls RequestFactory
services is in blue
on the right.
So let's look at an example of
an entity and entity proxy.
On the left, we have a named
list. This is an entity that
uses Objectify annotations.
So we have the @entity
and @ID in it.
It lives on the server
side of things.
And it has some code in it which
is not understandable by
GWT on the client.
Namely, that key type there,
which wouldn't be transferable
across the wire.
Notice that the proxy now
lives on the right side.
NamedListProxy is just
an interface.
Interface NamedListProxy
extends EntityProxy.
And it basically just defines
the public signature of our
entity on the client side.
So just the getters
and setters.
And you can notice also that
the proxy has to refer to
other proxy types.
So instead of referring to an
app user, which would be a
server-side entity, it has
to refer to AppUserProxy.
Instead of referring to
ListItem it refers to
ListItemProxy.
So everything on the client
side you're going to add
proxy, generally, when creating
your interfaces.
RequestFactory automatically
takes care of converting
between the proxy types
and the real types
on the server side.
Notice that our entity proxy on
the right side also has a
ProxyFor annotation.
This is how you tell it which
server-side class it
represents.
In this case it's NamedList and
it also has a locator here
which we'll talk about
in a second.
So all of your built-in value
types, basically String and
your primitive wrapper types in
Java like String, Integer,
Ebullient, et cetera,
are automatically
handled by GWT RPC.
You don't have to write
anything special.
Enums are also supported.
So in our proxy interface here
we've defined an enum
ListType, NOTES and TODO.
And we don't have to do anything
special to serialize
that across the wire.
It does not have to be located
in the proxy type.
It can be located anywhere
in a shared package.
And on the server-side,
RequestFactory just ignores
the annotations.
RequestFactory itself isn't
concerned with that.
Those are purely there for
Objectify in this case.
And then finally, notice that
we can send an embedded list
of items. So we're using the
embedded annotation to send a
list of items. And what that
will do is store the items in
our list along with the
list in the datastore.
This is the Objectify
annotation.
It's a powerful feature to be
able to store things together
as a package in datastore.
So that is an entity proxy.
Fairly simple.
Just an interface.
ValueProxy is even simpler
because value types don't have
ID inversion.
So here, a list item, which
is being included in the
collection of items in our
entity, just has a ProxyFor
annotation that identifies
the server-side class.
And note also that we can
use @ProxyFor for name.
So if you do @ProxyFor it's
actually looking for the Java
type, which means that
Java type has to be
on your class path.
But a lot of projects,
especially larger ones, will
split their GWT projects into
two separate projects, one
containing the client side
and one containing
the server-side code.
So you may not have the
server-side types on your
class path in the client.
And if that's the case, you can
use ProxyForName, give it
a fully qualified class path
as a string and then
RequestFactory will be able to
find it still at run time.
OK.
Let's look at our service
definitions now.
The service stub you see at the
bottom we're defining a
NamedListService.
And this is just a basic CRUD
service for our list object.
It references the service IMPL,
which in this case is
called NamedListDAO, because
it happens to be
a data access object.
And we have a locator
we'll talk about.
It just extends the
RequestContext interface.
And then all of the types
return, all of the methods,
return request objects.
This is what supports the
command pattern in
RequestFactory.
And then the request object is
parameterized with the real
return type.
So on the server your
implementation of this service
is going to return a list
of named lists.
But the client interface has to
say Request parameterized
with List of NamedListProxy.
So there's a little mapping
going on there.
And we're going to be bringing
out tooling in Google Plugin
for Eclipse that will give you
warnings when your server
interfaces, or your IMPLs,
don't match your
interfaces, et cetera.
Right now, that's a weakness
of this is that you have to
manually keep those
things in sync.
You'll get run time exceptions
if they don't match.
Oh sorry.
So at the top, we see
the RequestFactory.
This is what ties
it all together.
If we define multiple services,
then we would have
an accessor method for
each one in our
RequestFactory interface.
Here, for compactness,
we only have one.
And this is just a marker
interface that let's
RequestFactory know it has
to write some code
for all these services.
So how do we use it?
Well, once we've defined our
interfaces and our proxy
types, we do a GWT.create
on the RequestFactory.
This causes GWT to run a bunch
of generators which generate
the actual code that's
going to make the
service calls, et cetera.
We create our entity using the
Service.create method that's
on the RequestContext
interface.
We give it our proxy type, and
we'll get back an instance of
that object.
So in this case a taskProxy.
We can then call its setters.
And then call our method
to persist the task.
That would be a method
that we defined
in our service interface.
And then finally, fire it.
And fire it is equivalent to
your async call in GWT RPC.
This is what actually makes
the call to the server.
And just like GWT RPC
you had to pass an
async callback object.
Here we pass a receiver.
That's RequestFactory's
terminology for your callback.
And it has onSuccess, onFailure
and onViolation
methods similar to GWT RPC.
Finally, note that when you've
made a call to the server and
you get data back, then there
are entity proxy change events
that get fired if RequestFactory
determines that
something has changed
on the server.
And this is why entities have
the concept of ID and version
in RequestFactory.
So you can update the version.
You're responsible to
update the version
on the server side.
And when RequestFactory is
returning a response and it
detects that the version has
changed, say from three to
four, then it will trigger this
entity proxy change event
on the client.
So you can listen for that in
your presenters or widgets or
other classes to make
updates to the UI.
OK.
So let's look at some code,
how it all works together.
This is a method that will
create a new list object and
persist it on the server.
So we do reqCtx.create give it
our interface type, call the
setters, and then save
and return is our
method on the service.
We fire it.
We pass it a receiver.
And we implement the onSuccess
method that will do something.
In this case we're updating a
data table with our new cell
table structure.
Notice that we only
have to implement
the onSuccess method.
With GWT RPC, you also
had to do onFailure.
There's DefaultHandler for
failure in RequestFactory.
So we don't have to do that.
But you can always of course
wrap the receiver object.
You can extend it and provide
a default implementation of
your own for onFailure
or any other method.
OK.
Here's an update.
Now, this is important.
When something comes back from
the server with RequestFactory
it is immutable.
It cannot be changed.
And in order to tell
RequestFactory that you want
to make changes to it, because
remember we want to track
those changes, you have
to call the method
explicitly to do that.
So you're going to call
reqCtx.edit and pass it the
object that you got
from the server.
And that makes it editable.
You can then call
the setters and
fire a request. OK.
Let's look at a query.
This one is going to receive
back the list of objects from
the server.
And it calls the listAll method
and then you'll notice
there's this dot with.
So one of the issues with GWT
RPC was that it would
automatically bring back
a whole object graph.
And as your object graphs become
large, this can be
problematic.
Especially in Internet
Explorer.
There's various bugs and issues
you can find on that.
So with RequestFactory, we
wanted to give you control
over exactly which properties
in the object graph you want
to bring back.
So to do that you use
the dot with.
And you just specify the names
of the properties that you
want to retrieve.
So you can specify a comma
separated list, and you can
also use dot notation to drill
down more deeply into your
object graph.
And it'll walk that and bring
back only those items.
So this is required to bring
back any proxy types.
Any entity-related
DTO property.
So entityProxy or valueProxy,
you have to use dot with.
If you don't all you're going
to get back is the built-in
value types like the String
and Integer properties for
your entities.
So a little bit more
RequestFactory goodness here.
Validation is supported now
on the server side.
You can annotate your entities
with the JSR303 Bean
validation annotations like
@NotNull and Length.
And prior to invoking a service
method RequestFactory
will call the validation API,
will validate all the
entities, and will return any
validation violation to the
client, and then you can
handle them in your
onViolation method.
That would give you a set of
constraint violations that you
can handle.
So this happens before
any action is taken.
If there are violation
constraints then
RequestFactory will just abort
the action and won't actually
invoke the method on
the server side.
Some more goodies here are the
new editor framework, which
unfortunately we don't
have time to go into
this morning in depth.
But with editors you can
do data binding.
So this automates the process
of getting information from
the view to your model
and vice versa.
The boilerplate type of code
that's usually required there.
There's a good sample app for
this in the DynaTableRF.
And basically, the editor will
take away a little bit more of
the boilerplate code common for
updating persistence UIs.
It will also automatically give
you the property list for
your dot with clause.
So you don't have to manually
specify that.
It will infer that from the
things have been changed in
the UI, and then sends dot with
with all those properties
listed to the server.
So putting it together now.
Let's look at how you can use
RequestFactory with Objectify
to build a pretty light-weight
persistence layer in GWT.
You can annotate your entities
with Objectify.
Define your entity proxy
interfaces on the client.
And then, the cool part is we
can expose our DAOs directly
as RequestFactory services.
So if you think about what
you've done with the command
pattern, maybe using
gwt-dispatch or something, the
command pattern can be
kind of verbose.
So you have action and a result
for each command which
corresponds to one method
on a service.
Then you also have an action
handler on the server side.
And then your DAO and entity.
So to define a basic CRUD
service with four methods in
the command pattern,
you would actually
end up with 14 classes.
To do that same thing in
RequestFactory by just
exposing a DAO directly as a
service, all you need is your
entity proxy and your
service interface.
And so you end up with two
classes and two interfaces.
So let's look at an
example of that.
On the server side here we
have our NamedListDao.
This is our service IMPL.
We're actually exposing it as
a service to the client.
I've just shown one of the
methods here, the save method
to persist it to
the datastore.
And then on the client side,
we represent that as our
NamedList service that extends
RequestContext.
It just defines the method with
the signature using a
request for the return type.
And that's it.
You define your DAO.
You define your interface
on the client.
And that's it.
That's all the wrapper code you
have to write to actually
expose the DAO as a service.
So for persistence-oriented
services this is really ideal
because it gives you a very
quick way with little code to
implement CRUD services
and the like.
So the plumbing that's required
to make this work are
the locators which I've been
deferring until this point.
So RequestFactory, in order to
infer things like version
changes on the server, has
to be able to locate
or find your entities.
So in the original 2.1
implementation of
RequestFactory, you had to
provide static finder methods
on your entities themselves.
But that wasn't a very
flexible pattern.
It made it difficult to work
with dependency injection on
the server side.
And it's not a common pattern.
So in 2.1.1, I think it was, we
made it possible to define
a locator for an entity.
And the locator, its whole
job is just to find it.
So it makes the call, the query,
to the datastore and
brings back the entity.
Well, because Objectify uses
generics well in the DAOs, you
can actually write one Objectify
locator that will
work with all your Objectify
entities.
So only one class to make
all this come alive.
And similarly for the services,
RequestFactory
originally would actually call
static methods and those would
be your services.
But that doesn't work with
dependency injection at all,
because you need instances
of things.
So in 2.1.1 we made it to where
you could specify a
service locator, and that
would give you back an
instance of a service.
So now you can do service
inheritance as well.
And in the previous slide, you
noticed that the NamedListDao
extends ObjectifyDao.
So the only code I have to put
in my NamedListDao is code
that's specific to
that entity.
In this case I'm getting
the user and
setting an owner property.
But if I were just persisting
the entity I wouldn't have to
even have a method here because
it would just be
inherited from the
ObjectifyDao.
So you can make a really
lightweight CRUD persistence
layer using this.
So service locators enable you
to configure your services
through dependency injection.
And again, you can use one
generic service locator for
all services.
Basically, all you need on the
service is you implement the
service locator interface and
you return class.newinstance.
And it'll look at the service
class that it was requested
and just return a new
instance of it.
Or if you want to hook it into
Spring or Guice, then you call
the web application
context and get it
from your DI container.
So this is what an Objectify
entity locator looks like.
You can see it's very simple.
To create methods just call
class.newInstance to create an
instance of the requested
entity.
And then define method makes the
Objectify call to find it.
This one, I'm using a
datastoreObject as a
convenience.
By extending that base class,
having my entities extend
that, I can know that the ID
property is of type Long,
which makes my other methods
in this locator
a little bit simpler.
But you can also do it using
Reflection, because it's on
the server side, and avoid
even that little bit.
So your entities can just
be playing POJOs.
Don't have to extend
any class.
So to sum it all up, to make
a service layer with
RequestFactory and Objectify,
you have one entity locator,
one service locator, one
RequestFactory class.
Those are for your whole app.
And they're already written
for you, by the way.
If you look at the
sample projects
we'll put up in a minute.
And then your entity.
Each one has to have two
representations, but one of
them is just an interface
on the client.
Your service has an IMPL and
a service interface.
And that's about as lightweight
as you can make a
service layer actually in GWT.
But even for this we do have
some tooling coming out.
There'll be a presentation
sometime.
It's either today or tomorrow,
I can't remember, on using
Android for App Engine
development.
App Engine for Android?
Well, anyway.
And that presentation will be
showing some tooling in
GooglePlugin for Eclipse where
you can actually right click
and say, new service layer or
something like that and it
will create a lot of these
interfaces and code for you.
So watch this space
for tooling to
make this even user.
OK.
With that, I'd like to move to
the front end now to the UI.
You've heard about the
model-view-presenter framework.
And several frameworks emerged,
Mvp4g, gwt-dispatch,
gwt-presenter, and one of the
most recent frameworks has
been run by Philippe Beaudoin
who created it.
And today, we have, I'm pleased
to announce, Philippe
himself to talk about
the framework.
So welcome, Philippe.
PHILIPPE BEAUDOIN: OK.
So thanks, David.
So the rest of this talk is
going to be about the
gwt-platform, which we also call
GWTP so we can have the
cute little tepee as our logo.
OK.
So the goal of gwt-platform is
to actually make it possible
for you, the developers, to
build a large scale GWT
application while sticking to
the industry best practices.
So in there, you'll get a
presenter-centric model view
presenter framework.
There's also a common pattern
that's included in GWTP and a
couple of other goodies.
For example, there are
mechanisms to help you play
with your internationalization
strings.
Or just recently, in version
0.6 coming very soon, we'll
actually add some mechanisms
to let you make it possible
for your AJAX stage to be
indexed by a crawler.
So I call this a
presenter-centric
model-view-presenter
framework.
And the reason is that because
all the information is
actually located right
into the presenter.
You don't have to write
multiple classes.
It's all in the same place.
OK.
So a quick overview
of GWTP's MVP.
The first thing to know is that
GWTP's MVP predates GWT's
Activity and Places.
So it's not based on them.
However, we're working really
hard to bridge that gap now so
you can benefit both from
Activity and Places, and
GWTP's super simple
MVP syntax.
It's also an annotation-based
API, which means that most of
the time you can do in a single
line of code what would
otherwise take you a
couple of classes.
There's also support for nested
presenter, a little
feature we'll come back
into detail soon.
And there's also built-in
support for GIN, so you get
dependence injection on the
client, and much more which
we'll list at the end.
OK.
So in order to understand
GWTP let's start
with a quick example.
Let's say you want to build in
your web app some page that
welcomes the user to your app.
So in MVP world, it means you
have to write at least a
presenter and a view.
So this is how the view
would look into GWTP.
But the first thing you'll
notice is that we're extending
some class.
They're called ViewIMPL.
It's important to know that
ViewIMPL is an empty class
basically just providing default
implementation for
three methods.
So you don't have to actually
extend that class.
You can extend whatever
class you want.
For example Composite.
There is also it's implementing
some interface,
and we'll come back
to that soon.
But really the only important
thing in that class here is
the asWidget method you see
at the bottom there.
Basically, it says that your
view has to be able to be
represented as a widget.
You can create that widget
in any way you want.
In that particular case, we're
using UIBinder to create it.
But if you prefer to use
GWT Designer, or if you
instantiate the widgets
manually,
you're free to do that.
But the fun part is actually
the presenter itself.
So let's take a look at it.
Here, the first thing you'll
see is that we are defining
the interface we introduced
in the previous slide.
So we have my view here.
Right now, it's an empty
interface, but we'll fill it
with methods that the
presenter can use to
communicate with it's view.
We also have a second interface
here called MyProxy.
The proxy is actually the
fun part of GWTP.
It's using GWT code generation
tools in order to provide some
kind of shadow class
for the presenter.
The goal of this shadow class
is to actually make it
possible for your presenter to
be lazily loaded or to use
GWT's cold splitting.
So it's really easy to do cold
splitting with GWTP.
You'll only need that line,
your proxy code split, and
your presenter will
only be loaded the
first time it's requested.
And the last thing there is
just a constructor that
forwards all the resources
needed by a presenter to the
parent class who is going
to deal with it.
But you're free to
use any of these
resources if you need them.
OK.
So once you have a presenter,
something you really often
want to do is attach a URL
to that presenter.
So say, the user visits my web
page hash welcome, you should
get into that welcome
presenter page.
So in GWTP again, that's
easy to do.
Single line nameToken there,
and you indicate the name
token you'd like to attach
to your presenter.
And bang as soon as the
user visits that page
you get that presenter.
Now you often want to
attach a bit more
information to the URL.
For example let's say that here
we wanted a parameter on
the URL that says the user
name is Philippe.
So you can do that
again in GWTP.
And it's easy because the URL
is going to be parsed
automatically by
the framework.
And once it's parsed, the
framework is going to call a
method called prepareFromRequest
which you
see at the bottom here.
You get a place request. You
can grab any component you
want from the place request
and do whatever
you want with it.
So you have the parameters
there.
In that case we're calling the
method in the view in order to
set the user name right
in the view.
So you can see we've added a
method to the view interface
at the top, and we're
calling it from the
prepareFromRequest.
OK.
Now let's talk a little
bit about GWTP's
nested presenter feature.
The idea of the nested presenter
is that it leverages
the well-known principle of
hierarchy of widgets that you
all know and that you all use.
And it tries to bring that all
the way into the presenters
themselves.
So you can actually organize
your presenters hierarchically
without having to instantiate
the widgets that
are attached to them.
So you're free to test your
presenter hierarchy without
having to instantiate widgets,
or without the GWT test case.
It also brings a couple
of life cycle
events to the presenter.
You will now have things like
onReset, onReveal and onHide,
which will be called whenever
these events occurs, your
presenters, and all the way
down your hierarchy.
So let's say that you want a
top-level presenter in your
new presenter hierarchy.
So this top level presenter
would actually add children
presenters.
In that case, the view has to
be able to attach these
children presenters to
the parent presenter.
And this is done in the method
called setInSlot in the view.
Basically, it only looks at the
slot into which you want
to add the children presenter
and it adds the corresponding
widget there.
Three simple methods.
And this is only true if your
presenter can have children.
Otherwise, the view doesn't
need anything more.
Now on the presenter side, since
the presenter can have
children, it has to define a
couple of constants that will
be used to refer to
these children.
So here you can see two
of these constants.
The first one is called TOP_SLOT
and CENTER_SLOT.
They have been added
to the presenter.
And these can basically
be any kind of object.
So the first one is the
generate Java object.
The second one is slightly
more complex.
It's a GWT type platform.
The reason the second one is
more complex is because it's
going to allow us to use the
EventBus to decouple even the
parent presenter from
its children.
So the top-level presenter has
to reveal itself and say, I'm
going to occupy the full
page of the web app.
So to do that there's a
revealInParent method which we
left off earlier.
But every presenter needs
to have that.
And in the case of the top level
presenter, it actually
fires an event called
RevealRootContentEvent.
And that event is called by
GWTP and says, OK, now the
presenter is going to occupy
the entire page.
If you'd rather use GWT's
Layout Panel, there's a
slightly different event
that you can fire in
exactly the same way.
Now if you want to reveal a
children presenter that's
loosely coupled to its parent,
they can't talk
to one another directly.
What happens there is that the
children will actually fire an
event again that says, please
reveal me inside that slot.
The slot is just a constant.
It's not a reference to
the parent itself.
The parent will catch the event
and reveal the children.
The last little thing I'm going
to talk about is called
PresenterWidgets.
So sometimes you don't really
need to have that decoupling
between the parent presenter
and the children.
You just want some lightweight
mechanism to create reusable
components.
This is where PresenterWidgets
come in.
So PresenterWidgets are also
very useful if you have
tightly related presenters and
you don't want to go to the
trouble of decoupling
via the EventBus.
So an example in which I
personally tend to use
PresenterWidget, there's a
little login bar at the top of
your web app that
says, OK, well
you're logged in Philippe.
Log in, log out, stuff
like that.
So in that case, it's called
the loginPresenter.
You see there.
And for PresenterWidget what
we do is that we actually
inject them in the
parent presenter.
So you can see the injection
called here on the
constructor.
And then later at any point in
time, you are free to call the
method called setInSlot
and say, I want this
PresenterWidget to actually
occupy that top
slot in that case.
So in this example here, we're
doing that in onReveal.
So the first time this main
presenter is revealed, it's
going to install the login
presenter in the top slot.
But you are free to replace
it later or to
do that at any time.
So the last little thing is
that we're using GIN.
And all these nice little
components are interfaces that
we have to connect to
implementations and that we
have to connect to
one another.
This is done in the
GIN module.
There are couple of methods in
GWTP to help you do a lot of
bindings in one call.
So it's again few
lines of code.
And if you're interested to know
how to do that you can
look at the wiki.
There's also a custom
place manager
that you have to write.
This is basically just telling
your app, oh, if the user logs
in without a hash tag there
go to that default page.
Or if it's an error page, you
can define it in there.
So it's all defined in
the wiki, like I say.
But if you're using Eclipse,
you'll be happy to know that
with version 0.6 there will be
a new Eclipse plugin coming
out with GWTP that will let
you create all these
presenters and views and
connections between them with
a simple click of the mouse.
But I'd like to thank Michael
[? Renault ?]
and Imagine who actually
contributed that plugin.
[APPLAUSE.]
OK.
So quickly in summary, what
GWTP offers you is that
basically you can do MVP with
two classes, a presenter and a
view, which is the strict
minimum you need for MVP.
There is also super simple
history management through the
@token annotation.
You have nesting, so
nested presenters.
And there's also a lot more
inquiry due to Explorer.
So you can actually have tabbed
presenters with little
tabs at the top or dialogue
box presenters.
There are gatekeepers, which
allow you to do client-side
security so some pages are not
visible to some users.
ProxyEvent is a little
annotation that makes it super
easy to bind EventHandler
to events.
There are breadcrumbs
support if your
application needs that.
Annotation processors that
easily, automatically generate
events actions and DTOs.
And there's also the GWTP's
command patterns that is
packed full of features
like what we've seen.
There's also quick features I
want to bring your attention
on that's coming out
really soon too.
It's what we call GWTP's
Crawler Service.
And basically, it's a service
you can instantiate.
Right now, it's meant to
run in App Engine.
But it will make it easy for
your AJAX page to be crawlable
by search engines.
It's a feature that has been
requested for awhile.
I think it's going to be
really useful to you.
So in conclusion, I'd like to
thank Arcbees Consulting
who've been funding
the project.
Also BookDen.net who have
been using it a lot.
They've really helped.
But this project is an
open source project.
Lots of contributors on it, and
it would never be where it
is today without their help.
So I'd like to acknowledge
them.
So with that I'll hand
it over to David.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID CHANDLER: Thank you.
Thanks very much.
There's a couple of sample apps
that I want to point your
attention to for using
some of these things.
We have a project we created.
Philippe did most
of it actually.
The GWT GAE 2011 project shows
you how to use RequestFactory,
Objectify and gwt-presenter
all together.
gwt-platform, sorry.
ListWidget is something I did.
The user interface
is terrible.
I apologize.
The server-side code is fine.
Maven, Objectify,
RequestFactory.
And then, Turbomanage
is my personal blog.
Arcbees is Philippe's blog.
Googledevtools is our Twitter
account for the GWT team.
Let's see.
Sorry I didn't get your
blog up there, Jeff.
The best place to find Jeff
is actually on the
Objectify-Appengine mailing
list. Based on the frequency
and timing of posts that I've
seen, I'm pretty sure that
Jeff responds to the mailing
list while he's riding his
motorcycle to and from Central
America as he talked about in
the abstract.
So very responsive.
I want to give a huge
thank you to
the open source community.
We haven't mentioned them this
morning, but I want to
especially thank David Peterson
who created the
gwt-presenter and gwt-dispatch
frameworks based on Ray Ryan's
talk two years ago.
That framework was very
important in building this
whole community of MVP
architecture and GWT.
And gwt-platform actually uses
a lot of that code and is
built further on it.
So you all are the secret
to the success of these
platforms. I encourage you to
get involved in the open
source projects around
GWT and App Engine.
And let's see.
I just wanted to point out one
historic thing that's happened
here this morning.
We don't usually let people
talk at Google I/O until
they're Googlers or sometimes
external guys like Jeff.
But Philippe has done something
unusual in that he's
actually done his first
presentation at Google I/O
before he actually
joined Google.
He has been hired by Google,
I'm happy to say.
His Noogler training isn't
for a couple of weeks.
I'm a Noogler myself.
I joined last June so it was
before the last I/O.
So I just want to say, Philippe,
my hat's off to you.
[APPLAUSE].
Now I want to point out
one presentation.
We're going to mention that
RequestFactory tooling and the
Android App Engine
today at 3:45.
I also encourage you to stop by
the GWT office hours from
12:00 to 3:00 both days.
That's where you can get people
personally answering
your questions about GWT.
And finally, I encourage you
to visit the GWT Developer
Sandbox area out on the
second floor here.
We have 16 companies who are
using GWT in creative and
innovative ways.
And that's a great place
to talk geek.
There's also some of them, I
think there's a special offer
on a book there, and some other
things that you might be
interested in.
It's GWT developers.
We have about five
minutes left.
If you would like to ask a
question, can I ask that you
make your way to one of
the mikes so that it
can be on the video.
And maybe that's not such
a good idea with the
crowd we have here.
But if you can give it a shot.
We'll wait for you to
get to a mic there.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Hello.
I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I have a question for Jeff.
So do you think that Objectify
could be the next Hibernate?
I mean [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SQL [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SQL that the best
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JEFF SCHNITZER: I don't know how
to answer that question.
I hope not.
Hibernate is a very, very
complicated piece of software.
I hope Objectify never
gets to that point.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
Anyone else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Say I have variable
schemas on the server side.
Is there any way to apply the
RequestFactory details if I
don't know the schema of
the object in advance?
DAVID CHANDLER: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: Not offhand.
Thanks.
DAVID CHANDLER: You can write a
generic schema, but then at
that point it just becomes
basically a HashMap or a
properties bag or something
that you're
going back and forth.
And actually that will work, and
it will actually work with
App Engine because the
datastore doesn't
have to have types.
As Jeff showed at first, you
just have an entity which is
basically just a
properties bag.
So you can do it but not with
POJOs that you're redefining
on the fly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
DAVID CHANDLER: Question.
AUDIENCE: This question
is for Philippe.
Since Ray Ryan's talk, I really
got into the MVP thing.
And then with the activities
in Places, I kind of had
trouble mentally mapping between
that in view of MVP in
the Activity Places.
Do you any insights as
to how gwt-platform
going to tackle that?
PHILIPPE BEAUDOIN: Yes.
To be honest I haven't looked at
Activities and Places that
much myself.
From what I understand there,
it goes some way towards
helping you do the MVP
architecture, but you have to
do the rest of it yourself.
I'm not entirely sure.
I think that what GWTP will do
for is that it will actually
reduce the number classes you
have to write just because it
tends to use annotations instead
of asking you to write
multiple classes.
Beside that, I'm not
entirely sure the
difference between both.
DAVID CHANDLER: We're going to
talk about Activities and
Places tomorrow afternoon in the
high-performance GWT talk.
And you might get some
ideas there.
I think you could
create some--
or Philippe could create some
annotations for presenters for
example that would
also allow that
presenter to be an activity.
And you could co-generate some
of the code you need for that.
We should talk.
There's potential there.
PHILIPPE BEAUDOIN: I will
be attending this one.
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I am Marcello.
Last year, I remember you showed
us integration with the
Spring Roo.
Are the teams still
working together?
Are you going to add
these to Spring?
DAVID CHANDLER: We haven't
done a lot of development
building further
on Spring Roo.
My understanding is that Spring
has hired someone that
is working on the GWT
stuff full-time.
But I'm not real plugged into
that right now so I'm not sure
how much is really going on.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID CHANDLER: That's
the best I can say.
And just for curiosity how many
people are using Roo or
trying to use Roo?
A few people.
OK.
I'd be glad to get
your thoughts.
I'll be hanging around the
Developer Sandbox area later
today if you want to talk
about that more.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
One quick question.
What about Objective-C client
for RequestFactory?
I realize this is Google and
we have Android as a client
and GWT, but it's obviously a
big platform, big market that
we'd like to be able to deploy
to multiple clients.
DAVID CHANDLER: I'm sure if
the open source community
wanted to contribute an
Objective-C client for
RequestFactory, we probably
wouldn't turn it down.
But I don't think that's
something that we would be
working on.
OK.
I don't see anyone else
lined up at the mic so
thank you very much.